A delicate balance that governs
This holy site is under strain.
I know
my producer and I both Muslim-born
were granted access
to film
at the Aqsa compound
by the custodians of the site.
Only Muslims are allowed to pray
under a long standing status
quo arrangement
that worshipers tell us
is slowly being eroded.
Non-Muslims can visit
the complex during certain hours
I feel pain, true pain
this woman tells me.
This is a place of worship,
not a place for occupation
or for provocation.
This is what she means.
While we speak, a group of large
Jewish visitors
passes by the mosque under polic
The women demonstrate
by reciting the Koran louder
and louder, loudly.
This mountaintop is revered by J
They call it Temple Mount.
A growing movement of Jewish ext
is demanding
to perform prayers here
that could upend the status quo.
We witnessed
at least two men
praying as police stand by.
We've seen several
small groups
like this of non-Muslim worshipe
passing through the complex
as Muslims
continue to pray inside the mosq
This is where the friction is.
This is where the controversy li
Jordan is the custodian of the g
but that role is becoming
increasingly symbolic.
Experts say
because it is Israel
that controls
the security checks at entry poi
and therefore access
the director
general of Al-Aqsa sees
the increasing visits
of Jewish extremists under polic
as a provocation.
Daniel Murphy.
I was coming off of it.
I see these visits as an attack
on our holy site, he tells me.
And I warned the government of I
to stay away from Al-Aqsa Mosque
because any violation here
drags down the entire regional
level.
And there are tons at the gates.
Small groups of Jewish radicals
saying the temple will be built.
A reference to a far right fring
to build a third temple
on the sacred grounds.
Prime Minister Netanyahu
insists
he is committed
to keeping the status quo
but under his government,
the most far right in Israel's h
Extremist voices are growing lou
and stronger.
All this makes an already
extremely contentious place
ever more of a tinderbox.
One event here can and has spark
deadly cycles
of violence across the region.
Al-Aqsa is seen as a political s
as well as a religious one
by the Arab world.
The complex lies
in the heart of East Jerusalem,
which most of the international
considers to be under Israeli oc
but which Israel sees
as part of its united capital en
Al-Aqsa is our life.
It is the breath we breathe, he
It is an ideology that we carry
in our minds on the wall as we e
the Dome of the Rock.
An area
designated for women
to witness the afternoon prayer.
Some go to great lengths to get
passing multiple checkpoints.
But they tell us
they find some peace when they a
And of course, I don't feel safe
she tells me.
And everything can change in an
So I'm always scared.
But I'm here because I have fait
All of them
This prayer passed peacefully,
as most do.
But here,
even quiet worship is not a guar
Some of these CNN Jerusalem.